un joven ruso de origen checheno de 18
años que tenía estatus de refugiado en
francia así fue como la fiscalía
antiterrorista reseñó al autor del
atentado perpetrado este viernes en el
que el profesor de secundaria francés
samuel para ti fue decapitado
el individuo neutralizado poseía un
permiso de residencia expedido el pasado
4 de marzo válido hasta marzo de 2030 y
bajo el nombre de abdulá abu ha sido
vichy nacido el 12 de marzo de 2002 en
moscú rusia y residía en ebro en el
departamento de agua el sujeto no era
conocido por los servicios de
inteligencia and service del sismo las
autoridades informaron que el atacante
pidió a varios jóvenes que identificarán
al maestro de historia geografía que
había mostrado dos caricaturas satíricas
de mahoma en su clase sobre libertad de
expresión y comportamientos cívicos
este profesor fue asesinado por lo que
representaba la repubblica fue asesinado
por lo que simbolizaba conocimiento en
servicio del pensamiento crítico el
desarrollo de los ciudadanos que son
libres e ilustrados lo cual está en el
corazón de lo que hacemos cuando
enseñamos con un fusil y con al menos
diez personas permanecen bajo custodia
entre ellos varios familiares del joven
y dos padres de estudiantes del colegio
que habían iniciado una campaña contra
el profesor en redes sociales y habían
exigido su despido desde la escuela
confirmaron haber recibido amenazas tras
la publicación de los vídeos hay
movilizaciones de solidaridad y en
defensa de los valores de la república
previstas para el domingo y un homenaje
nacional hasta miel para ti el próximo
miércoles